you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens hey there ladies and
gentlemen welcome back to the game spot
co-op stage I am Chris waters here in
the host share joined by three fine
hosts here on the couch andrea renee
iJustine and jeff cannata ah y'all we've
been having some really interesting
discussions about a breath of III stuff
one of the topics we are going to the
top of her in a wrap with now is
reinvented franchises games franchise is
coming back from the distant past or
maybe more recent games just getting a
whole new kind of vibe a whole new kind
of look let's start off with one of the
biggest new announcements of e3 2016
quake I'm so excited couch just Queens
higher high school experience was like
we had a quake hidden on like secret
directories so we would go in and play
like we supposed to be doing within our
computer programming classes like oh we
would have our programs done really
really quickly and then we'd be like all
right I'll tab and then we would start
playing quake and so for me that is like
where I really started playing pc
first-person shooters and we would go to
like cyber cafes back in the day cuz
that was a thing and so when eyes you
lived in a cool town it wasn't that cool
but he doesn't have like two and a half
hours to get there okay being able to
like go back and just play quake and
obvi I'm nice oh alright looks like we
ask you this then so do you want it to
be like full-on old-school quake you
want it or do you want to have some
fresh new element to it I think I do
want to have it a little bit fresh like
even we're talking about dhoom two
before cameras came back on like it just
feels fast or feels pressure because I
think you do sort of need that kind of
thing um so I'm excited to see what they
do with it yeah so what did you like
about quake to you in terms of gameplay
what was like what's the fat thing that
you like that like really needs to be
represented as the soul of that game I
mean I love being able to sort of just
play with people and have sort of that
fun competitive kind of advantage to as
well and just have it mean quick arena
it was I don't know I just I'm so
speechless excited I got to talk to Tim
Willits from
did yesterday everything so it was
interesting because he um he you know
echoes the sentiment of fans obviously
he's going to it a long time think we
want to keep it you know quintessential
quake but now we're in a whole new era
of hardware and you know they said it's
going to be an unlocked frame rate it
will move as fast as the hardware you
can throw at it and I said that's a
really interesting idea I said this is
this a new pay-to-win is it a new like
however much pc i can afford is like how
much better of an experience i can have
an interesting idea because you know
we're in this very competitive eras like
well how is that going to affect eSports
particularly with wake and and then also
on the other side you know what is going
to be different you talk about unique
champions with special abilities you
know and obviously there is it's rooted
in quakes you know origins but it really
kind of smacked me of hero shooter oh
yeah I asked him straight up would you
call us a here street I hear shooter and
he said yes well that's the that's the
new hotness right we got overwatch we
got lawbreakers is gonna be that battle
born yeah battle morin i mean i think i
think the MOBA influence on competitive
multiplayer shooters is is tangible and
i think actually that's really fun i
mean i'm enjoying overwatch so much
because of that and it's better than
just like waiting for a spawn of a
weapon but it's very much different than
wait gray for sure and i think the hard
part two with eSports is trying to keep
that competitive advantage but also keep
it an even playing field for all the
players so that's gonna also be sort of
interesting like how are they gonna work
that out and different things like that
another things you were talking about
before it like the xbox arena like how
are they gonna do this and make sort of
eSports for everyone yeah very
intriguing that i was talking with aaron
greenberg yesterday about the arena and
they're hoping I cuz one day I want to
you know throw like the chris waters
Invitational rocket League tournament on
a weekend Chris waters memorial memorial
I mean we just remember when I used to
play video games I mean I'm still shop
healthy ah but yes please do that we'll
put that in my will
my tragic passing I just seeing you
mentioned another game we're going to
talk about during this segment recently
released to rave reviews doom man I had
such a good time we did one of the the
launch event so we did a tournament with
of like a bunch of different athletes
and I was teamed up with Antonio Brown
which I was so excited because I'm from
Pittsburgh so being able to play in sort
of our competitive tournament with
Antonio and we ended up actually winning
I mean it still has yeah right although
he took the trophy and I really wanted
haha Antonia please yeah yeah yeah uh
but it's just so funny that still has
that feel of like old-school doom but
yet you know feels new it feels fresh
and it's fast well I think the magic
sauce they found with doom is saying hey
there was a time when every shooter
didn't behave the same or maybe they all
did behave the same but it's different
than they behave now there was a time
when you didn't run behind cover and
wait for your help to replenish you
actually they were actually health packs
and actually I think they figured out a
really fun way to incentivize moving
forward through the game rather than
retreating and getting better I mean
healthier and I think that that that
mentality that sort of old-school
mentality it was we were right for a
return to that and uh I don't know if
quake is the same I don't know if quake
I feel like there's three or four
different projects that all said hey
we're gonna be that old kind of quake
game lawbreakers is that that John
Romero Kickstarter computer is that he
so I don't know I feel like there's a
glut of those and I don't know doom was
first to be like look here it is yeah I
mean they did such a good job and even
just the reviews and even my friends
like back in the day when we used to
again hide it on secret directories it
was just cool because it really did have
that feel but for people who might have
never played it like kids today like
yeah I'll pick this up I'll play it I
think one of the things for me the doom
did was I mean it looks gorgeous like
all the effects it's egmond gorgeous
very gory and gross but it's also what I
was imagining when i was playing doom
back in the day like when that imp
crumbles in this bloody mess i'm
imagining what happens in
do now but I'm now getting to see it and
question my own sanity ah all right
let's shift gears away from the shooter
for a second and talk about a game
that's had a great showing here at the
show The Legend of Zelda breath of the
wild this is in many ways I mean here's
the question is this a reinvention of
Zelda formula or is it going all the way
back to that very first cell done I mean
I think it's an evolution I mean it's a
completely different gameplay experience
from the sense of perspective but at the
you know heart of what Zelda is this
exploration puzzle game adventure mm-hmm
it's it ticks all those boxes I mean and
Jeff you obviously had most hands-on
time with anybody here but when you look
at it even the art style looks like
Zelda it puts you right back in that
world and the music and the the vistas
and everything just really encapsulate
what Zelda is but with a whole new
experience I gotta say I've seen it you
know in the trailer and in the demo that
like walking through the grass off up to
the sort of cliff area to like
overlooked I still like get a little
flutter yeah it's like inside it's like
it's calling to me I don't know and not
you know I've played a bunch of Zelda
games over the years and grown
increasingly sort of dissatisfied with
the console ones as they shackle you to
these lengthy tutorial sequences and you
know I understand they're trying why
they would do that but you know that
original Zelda on NES a lot of people
it's still their favorite because it
puts you in the world with relatively
little fanfare or direction and was like
adventure yeah well we don't know I mean
there's a lot more to toot here there's
no maybe more tutorials because there's
a lot to toot I mean there are a lot of
systems in this game is what I mean to
say and I think that's kind of exciting
the idea that you're in a Zelda world
that you can just hang out in we've
never had that really I mean maybe that
first one but even that it what you are
moving from point to point giving the
next thing to get you the next you know
tell in the temple yeah and here it
feels like there really is a whole wide
variety of things to do to just hang out
in that
world cook things and hunt and you know
it's it's incredible there and the fact
that all of the weapons in the game
deteriorate and break down so you're
constantly there's an there's an
ecosystem of resources so you're it
requires you to constantly be getting
new weapons and replenishing their
supplies of things and cooking things to
give you bonuses and replenish your
health I mean are there even bottles
that get fairies in I don't know you
replace your help with food in this game
Oh are these f'n bottles is so fun it's
got its got it the my favorite part
about the weapons you're degrading over
time is I don't feel bad about just
chucking them at people right being able
to throw things at people in video games
is one of my personal favorite things to
do I thought like a lot of work I'm
exhausted already yeah cooking in a game
I don't you like one shop on a tree and
it explodes into kindling that's good do
they mention anything at all about how
amiibo might play into this at all or
well they showed the wolf a meebo if you
stick the wolf amoeba on the wii u you
get a wolf companion wolf link hangs out
with real link i don't know how that
works in the lore well uh but he hangs
out and he'll hunt for you and do cool
stuff for you any be your dog friend Oh
worth you media brings me back squirrel
mean we are good alright that's enough
talking about totally age-appropriate
games let's talk about bloody horrible
killing again god of war god of war made
us super splash at the beginning of
Playstations press conference I you know
talk about throwing weapons at people
right yeah you are in for some fun yeah
it's okay all right mr. I've played in
behind closed doors let that what you
throw it and then a separate button to
pull it back okay you decide when you
want to have it you throw it and then
you can like melee a dude and then pull
it in its it's for the game you're Thor
you know how Thor throws his hammer and
then anytime you want any punches
another guy and then he's like bring me
back my hammer in the idea that part
when Thor did that yeah without we're
touring yeah a result adjustable on for
ya so Fredo this is back uh he has
apparently washed off the ashes of his
dead family so he has a lot relatively
normal skin tone got a beard look
a little old and he's got a little kid
ah dad Kratos how he feel about this
he's not fit to be anybody's father
let's do it absolutely true absolutely
true i gotta for you know this it's a
warning dale there's some interesting
moments though in that trailer of you
know uh yeah that cold disappointment
the like you know don't be sorry be
better like that harsh like yeah okay
like this is what gredos trying his
level best to be a dad it looks like
it's kind of grim but I you know that
making a relationship part of that game
and not our relationships that's great
Oh swishing that someone wasn't dead or
wishing that someone was dead those are
pretty much as two notes honestly this
this is one of the highlights of the
entire convention for me because I think
it represents where we are as an
industry and it gives me so much hope
because this franchise is so
traditionally juvenile I mean it's about
boobies and killing stuff and yelling
and and it is a very specific kind of
thing and that's fun and we still have a
lot of that or but we have what we were
getting more and more of is what this
game looks to be so much richer and
deeper and subtle and nuanced and about
something right like you talk about him
being an unfit father I think that's the
journey of this character I think by the
end he's gonna learn something from his
son he's gonna soften and we're gonna
see actual character development and
have something that is a piece of
entertainment that's that sits alongside
other narrative pieces of entertainment
as makes me feel and think and and
actually have it be about something and
I find that so hopeful it's really good
point too because I can take this
franchise in a whole different world i
mean you know what could the next one be
okay i don't know it's just it's really
interesting and man this trailer was so
good i mean kratos is totally gonna die
at the end and then the next one is the
boy oh yeah but spoilers i think that
when you talk about reboots but you know
what we're doing in this whole segment
the just the vision
will change between this at the previous
you know we can even just go to the
trilogy I've it looks completely
different I mean the perspective is
really different it has this like
grittier feel to it a lot of people that
I talk to about it we're saying it kind
of feels a lot like the last of us in a
certain way visually um you know this
really you feel like you're part of the
world and the God of War franchise is
known for having these really rich
visuals and to begin with you know like
I remember playing God for three and
just being wowed by some of the
cinematics and the scale of that game
too hey we're playing a level that turns
out to be on the back of a Titan that's
climbing a giant mountain a little kiss
this thing that we see on screen right
now this troll fight they said this is
not a boss battle this is a just a
random character that you will encounter
a few times in the game this is craig
raid boss battles are going to be even
bigger scale than this so i think we're
not more of that re intrigued by the
parent sort of shift from greek roman
mythology to norse mythology I think
it's cool yeah yeah I mean I you need to
bring up last of us I think that and and
sort of that what they did with tomb
raider and an uncharted not a dog is is
at the forefront of what I'm talking
about with regards to being hopeful for
the industry that its strong Italian
evening richness of storytelling and I
just think to do that with God of War I
find that to be so exciting it's alright
yeah taking on the most unlikely one
yeah I'll have that kind of change let's
talk about one more before we wrap here
this is one was kind of a deep cut going
all the way back to 2000 whenever when
the little game called pray came out
first person shooter starring a Native
American named Tommy hawk yeah really
and it went on to me like a shooter of I
would some people remember very fondly I
think that it you know had some clues
horrible must not have played it Oh Jeff
did you not remember Stan our of that
game is awesome but after that it's not
good a lot of aliens uh your girlfriend
gets turned into a giant scorpion alien
it's pretty brutal you gotta you gotta
yeah
a lot of space stuff at the end that is
not there some gravity stuff those
engines yeah when you died you went to a
land of wind and ghosts and then if you
just shot the ghost you were alive again
right is not any of those things anymore
I don't even know why they're using the
same name like it's a great confusing
and you know I I talked him some people
about this I talked to Andrew Goldfarb
about this home around I Janet we were
like why they even like making this the
same so there's a lot of cachet in that
name and I made a joke about it while
they've got the trademarks and the copy
rides in the pillow tonight that stuff
like maybe they're just like recycling
it but it doesn't feel like praying on
and I think that they probably would
have been better off I didn't get really
especially given that they did show a
prey to a couple years ago and this is a
totally different game but the game that
it is let's talk about the trailer we
saw during the pyth esta press
conference I sort of a groundhog day
looking kind of trailer just one sort of
person guys going through his routine
seems to be doing the same kind of thing
every day transport some stuff to a
weird place for their shadow things
attacking him he's also in space I mean
did you guys get anything out of it that
you thought was intriguing I was very
intrigued we're not intrigued yeah i was
jus got intrigued obviously he's got
some kind of something happening with
his eye oh you got a pink guy it's a
game about pink eye well i think that
the eye thing is like all right I'm
going back to this eye thing to do my
get my whatever my powers or this is the
simulation going I think there's a lot
of Easter eggs in there too Pete Hines a
sort of the director of PR over there
was saying watch that trailer a few more
times if you're interested you might
spot a few more things in there but yeah
bringing that one back rebooting a
franchise it could he wanting to call
the franchise to begin with one game
really I don't know I thought I thought
that game looked really cool i love the
psychological element that they're
bringing in and i want to see more of
that I was really intrigued by what I
saw for sure maybe it's a good reboot
just well but I would have been guarding
shrieked if they'd shown that trailer
and then a different title came up i
would have been just as entry i want to
see that game and yeah the fact that it
came up with a title like that I was
like well that's alright yeah hi all
right any reboots kicking around in your
brain that you just like you want that
one to come back that maybe doesn't
exist or maybe you another one we
haven't talked about that you're excited
about I'll go what we haven't talked
about that just
came out like a kabacan week ago was
mirrors edge oh yeah music catalyst is
you know a lot of people like the first
thought it was gonna be like a sequel or
an origin story prequel excuse me but
it's actually more of a reboot is it
yeah I think it's kind of just a
spirited I got it sir I got flamed by
the internet when i call that they're
like listen here uh-huh you got this
wrong there are some opinions out there
and so I was like okay okay my bad my
bad um it's a it's a reboot and you know
I thought what they did with that game
was you know I thought they did a great
job rebooting it notice mixed opinions
out there about about mirrors edge but I
thought that was one that I was a lot of
fans were excited to see come back how
the conceptual gameplay yeah II III last
year everyone was like super excited
that it was being worked on but what did
you do you guys play it uh Mirror's Edge
I haven't had a chance cuz it kind of
came out right now yeah I love that it
happened and I really want to play it
but I haven't had a chance but I you
know resident evil has a seven at the
end of it but I think it's a reboot
right he played it I don't know what was
going on in VR I mean there was like
mannequins falling in front of me and
they were scaring like the things that
shouldn't scare you was like scaring the
crap out of me like which is the crazy
part about VR because the things that
are supposed to scare you are gonna
scare you extra heavy resident evils
known for the jump-scares what a kid now
that game can't look anything less like
resident evil I mean it's especially
recent Resident Evil's have not really
necessarily been about that kind of
horror tone that rat lighten our action
red they've much more action based yeah
and so to see that it's yeah up game
that's gonna be fully in VR and also
really leaning a lot towards I think the
trends the success is found by a lot of
indie horror titles recently right it's
intriguing for me even though I will not
play it haha I'm gonna even on VR you
wouldn't play it I man I could scare
real easy no lights on you know like in
broad daylight we've got a friend it's
fine in broad daylight but then when I
go to sleep they visit me in my dreams
and I don't sleep well and I get real
cranky your dimensions before you go to
bed you'll be from the palate cleanser
in there exactly I've tried it it
doesn't work well really exciting I
think to have excitement around reboots
especially in an industry when we have a
lot of nostalgia fueled you know
decisions made by
companies to have ones that we sort of
are interested in or see hope in or have
a great time with or you know flail
around and just get super giddy excited
about it's a great sign well my hope is
that every game will have a LEGO version
to be on it Lego I just want to be so
happy like I think it was like when the
lego movie game came out I played it on
xbox I played it on TS and then I played
it on PC and it was like well I'm happy
well not sure this event like Legos
Skyrim would be pretty rad gotta be
great my goodness you guys I'm sure the
sponsors of this nature gonna be very
happy and I have a problem dude he gave
you back they are really awesome and
they sponsored this segment and so thank
you to them and thank you to all of you
for joining us for day two of our live
coverage here from the game spot co-op
stage andrea renee iJustine jeff cannata
thank you all so much thank you Chris no
blast it's hang out with you guys and
talk about games and we've got more
coming for you tomorrow folks come on
back to gamespot com at 10am format Pat
and more gamespot coverage of e3 2016
until then have a great night